prototypes come in various forms some
are paper some are clickable screens
some are built using code no matter the
medium one thing these prototypes have
in common is their intended purpose the
core purpose of a prototype is to help
you communicate the story of your app to
your stakeholders for feedback or
research sessions this stops you from
wasting time building a really polished
product that has really glaring flaws
prototyping is not just specific to the
tech industry product design companies
and car manufacturers have been
utilizing prototypes from the very
beginning prototyping is a way to help
you make the best decisions possible
around the user experience of your
product it helps you make key decisions
and build better products through moving
through various stages which we'll talk
about later it's been said that an
estimated 50% of engineering time is
spent doing rework that could have been
avoided
what's more fixing an error after
development is up to a hundred times as
expensive as it would have been before
customers who have a positive user
experience are gonna be more likely to
stick with your products and become your
brand advocates now let's take a look at
the various stages of prototyping that
we'll cover in this course